How do I get all, like, programming complete in my night program?
I can't stay in bed for the entire time.
Well, this is a common scenario.
So many times I'll write the programs between eight and nine hours long
and then you've got some people that they just sleep seven hours every night.
So if that's a case and you are missing like more than an hour and a half every night,
then I will, you know, let me know and I will shorten up your programs.
If you're only missing a half an hour a night, the frequencies are cycling through them.
So I just said somebody sent me an email. They're not on this Zoom call, but they sent
me an email saying another practitioner wants them to run these three very specific frequencies.
I don't remember what it was. It was like 47.79 Hertz and I don't know,
39.82 Hertz and 147.3 Hertz and they want them run for four hours each day.
Okay, so I haven't talked to that person yet as they just sent me an email,
but they're that practitioner who's asking them to do that is not understating frequencies
very well because from a rife frequency standpoint, you're really not supposed to
run a specific frequency for more than about three to six minutes.
Now you can run it for three minutes and then run something else for three minutes and another
thing for two minutes and another thing for three minutes and then an hour later you can run it
again. That's a frequency, but you would never run a frequency for just like four hours.
You would just you would never do that. That could be actually harmful. All your programs, you could
actually look through your programs if you want. Please don't mess around in your programs because
you could mess it up. But when you hit run on your on your rife, the true rife and the
Atelier Robin, you can actually see the program that I wrote that's in there. It has all these
numbers, it has pulse rates and duty cycles and dwells and all these different things. The command
dwell, DWEL, is actually how long it will stay on the given frequencies until that dwell cycle has changed
again. So if I write dwell and then I write a whole bunch of numbers underneath there, those are the
frequencies and then you know it could go down a whole line and then there's another dwell. So my
dwell at 180 and then down a whole bunch of lines and it'll dwell at 80. That means it dwells at
180 seconds. And then if I change the dwell down below to 80, then it dwells at 80 seconds. You would
never dwell for how many seconds is is four hours. I don't know. So four hours times 60 minutes per hour
or times 60 seconds per year. So you could do the math, but there's no, you don't dwell that long.
And that comes from the understanding. I mean, royal rife said you should never run a frequency
more than three minutes. He was around radio frequencies. It could be very dangerous on his machine.
So they could actually burn somebody. But it's still an understanding in the rife community. You don't
dwell more than about six minutes. That would be your maximum dwell. And you do that very infrequently.
So given, let's say, let's pretend breast cancer is the program that we're running there. There
are about a hundred known frequencies for breast cancer. And I will program them, your program through
those frequencies, you know, for maybe let's say three hours and then they cycle again, then they cycle
again. So if you're missing a half hour of your program every night at the end, you're getting those
frequencies throughout the night. So we don't need to shorten your program. I'm very hesitant to,
short, as somebody says, oh, my programs are eight to the half hours long. And I sleep eight hours
and I don't sleep any longer than that. So I feel like I'm missing time. You're really not missing time.
You're getting those frequencies. So understand, if I'm going to shorten somebody's program,
so I had a gentleman, prostate cancer, he says, I only sleep six hours. So I'm not getting all my
programs. So, okay, well, we had that made sense. So we shorten this program. But the negative
of that is we're shortening the dwell that it's running on every frequency, which is good and bad.
You know, it's good because you're not missing it out. You're only in bed for six hours, but you're
missing out at three possible more hours of treatment time. So there's a balance that one plays.
And I don't want everybody to say, well, I want you to shorten my program too, because, you know,
I'm missing 20 minutes on every night. No, don't, don't do that. But if you're missing like two hours,
an hour and a half, let's say you only sleep six and a half hours. No, there's no exceptions to that.
You're never in bed longer than that. Then let me know. I'll gladly shorten the dwell and compact your
program. You're not getting as much treatment though. So that's the negative. So somebody that's
stayed in bed for eight hours and getting their rest and relaxing or maybe going to bed, I only sleep
for seven and a half hours. We'll go to bed early and read your Bible for a half an hour. At least
you're getting eight hours of program. You didn't follow my thinking on that. So just go along with
it. I don't want everybody to say I want you to shorten my program. I have to charge you for that because
it's a pain in the butt to do that. It takes time. But I understand if you're missing an hour and a half
each night. But if you're only missing a half hour on the average of each night, no, you're getting
those frequencies. We're not going to shorten your program for that. Hopefully that, I explain that.